والشيء المثير حقًا هو
أنك ترى العديد من اللاعبين الرئيسيين في
الشرق الأوسط يقررون
اتباع نهج مختلف ، وهو نهج جديد
لبعض مشكلاتهم طويلة الأمد
مدفوعة بمعتقدين ، أحدهما حقًا
هو أن الولايات المتحدة لديها قدرة أقل على
الالتصاق  من ذي قبل ولكن أيضًا
لأنهم يبدو أنهم يعتقدون حقًا
أن هناك حاجة إلى نهج جديد لأن هذه
الأساليب القديمة لم تنجح ، هذا
شيء
قاله لي وزير الخارجية الأردني مؤخرًا حول
سبب الموتى وعودة
العلاقات شبه الطبيعية.
مع سوريا على سبيل المثال ورأينا أم
وزير خارجية الإمارات العربية المتحدة في
دمشق في ذلك اليوم الرئيس السوري
بشار الأسد بكل المقاصد
والأغراض من المتوقع أن يكون نوعًا من
الترحيب بالعودة إلى
الحظيرة العربية وما رأيك في
ذلك؟
حسنًا ، أعني ما نحتاج إلى
فهمه وأعتقد مرة أخرى أه بيكي أن السنوات الـ 11
الماضية
منذ انتفاضات الربيع العربي في 2011
2012 كانت ستشهد حروبًا باردة إقليمية متعددة
و  أعتقد أن السيناريو أعتقد أن
أه المنطق يخسر يخسر الجميع فقد
خسر ، لذلك نحن نتحرك الآن من الخسارة
إلى الفوز -
لا الرئيس أودوان ولا الشيخ
محمد بن زايد الزعيم الفعلي
للإمارات العربية المتحدة
حقًا  يتخلون
عن مكاسبهم الإقليمية لكنهم يحاولون
بشكل أساسي إدارة منافسيهم ولماذا
لسبب بسيط يقوم الأمريكيون
بتقليص الروس في
أه هناك فراغ أمني إقليمي
أه الوضع الاقتصادي
رهيب حقًا كما تعلمون في كل مكان
حتى  في الخليج أه لأنهم لا يستطيعون
الاعتماد فقط على النفط والطاقة ، لذا
فإن مجموعة من المتغيرات حفزت بالفعل
اللاعبين الإقليميين على الدفاع عن
أنفسهم ومحاولة إيجاد طرق
للتعايش مع بعضهم البعض والتي
آمل أن يكونوا مع بعضهم البعض  انتقلت من هذه
المرحلة بالذات من خفض التصعيد إلى
المرحلة التالية
لإيجاد طرق لإنشاء بنية أمنية جديدة
حيث
تشتعل الحروب الأهلية الكبرى والحروب الكبرى في  اليمن
وليبيا ولبنان والعراق سيجدون أساسًا
طرقًا لحلها
وتحقيق السلام والاستقرار والازدهار
ما زلنا بعيدين لكنهم على الأقل
اتخذوا الخطوة الأولى في
رحلة طويلة